what if you could use genetic
engineering to stop humanity's most
dangerous predator the deadliest animal
on the planet responsible for the death
of billions the mighty mosquito along
with other diseases it plays host to
malaria one of the cruelest parasites on
earth possibly the single biggest killer
of humans in history in 2015 alone
hundreds of millions were infected and
almost half a million people died a new
technology could help us eradicate
malaria forever but to do so we need to
engineer a whole animal population this
is not a hypothetical problem the
modified mosquitoes already exist in a
lab should we use the technology and is
malaria bad enough to risk it
[Music]
malaria is caused by a group of
microorganisms plasmodia very weird
microorganisms that consist of just a
single cell they're parasites that
completely rely on mosquitoes malaria
always starts with an insect bite in its
saliva glands thousands of sporozoites
wait until the insect penetrates your
skin immediately after invading you they
head for the lever where they quietly
enter big cells and hide from the immune
system for up to a month they stay here
in stealth mode consuming the cells
alive and changing into their next form
small drop like merozoite they multiply
generating thousands of themselves and
then burst out of the cells so thousands
of parasites head into the bloodstream
to look for their next victims red blood
cells to stay unnoticed they wrap
themselves in the membranes of the cells
they killed imagine that killing someone
from the inside and then taking their
skin as camouflage
they now violently attack red blood
cells multiplying inside them until they
burst then finding more red blood cells
and this cycle repeats over and over
pieces of dead cells spread lots of
toxic waste material which activates a
powerful immune response causing
flu-like symptoms among the symptoms are
high fever sweats and chills convulsions
headaches and sometimes vomiting and
diarrhea
if malaria breaches the blood-brain
barrier it can cause coma
and neurological damage or death the
parasites are ready for evacuation now
when another mosquito bites the infected
human they get a right the cycle can
start over in 2015 the Zika virus which
causes horrible birth defects if it
infects pregnant women spread rapidly
into new areas around the globe it too
is carried by a mosquito the mosquito is
the perfect carrier for human diseases
they've been around for at least 200
million years there are trillions of
them and a single one can lay up to 300
eggs at a time they are practically
impossible to eradicate and the perfect
parasite taxi but today we have a new
revolutionary technology that could
enable us to finally win the war against
them
CRISPR for the first time in human
history we have the tools to make fast
large-scale changes to entire species
changing their genetic information as we
please so instead of attacking isolated
groups of insects why not just change
the types that transmit diseases using
genetic engineering scientists
successfully created a strain of
mosquitoes that are immune to the
malaria parasite by adding a new
antibody gene that specifically targets
pasmo diem these mosquitoes will never
spread malaria but just changing genetic
information is not enough the edits
would only be inherited by half the
offspring because most genes have two
versions inside the genome as a
fail-safe so after just two generations
but most only half of the offspring
would carry the engineered gene in a
population of billions of mosquitoes
they would hardly make a difference a
genetic engineering method
called the gene Dr solves this problem
it forces the new gene to become
dominant in the following generations
overpowering the old gene almost
completely thanks to this twist 99.5% of
all the engineered mosquitoes offspring
will carry the anti malaria edit if we
were to release enough engineered
mosquitoes into the wild to mate with
normal mosquitoes the malaria blocking
genes would spread extremely quickly as
the new gene becomes a permanent feature
of the mosquito population Plasmodium
would lose its home base scientists
hoped that the change would be so fast
that they could not adapt to it quickly
enough malaria could virtually disappear
if you take into account that maybe half
a million children are killed by it
every year about five have died since
this video started some scientists argue
that we should use the technology sooner
rather than later
the mosquitoes themselves would probably
only profit from this they don't have
anything to gain from carrying parasites
and this might only be the first step
malaria might just be the beginning
different mosquitoes also carry dengue
fever and Zika ticks transmit Lyme
disease flies transmit sleeping sickness
fleas transmit the plague we could save
millions of lives and prevent suffering
on an unbelievable scale so why haven't
we done this yet for one CRISPR editing
is barely four years old so until very
recently we just couldn't do it as fast
and easily and there are valid concerns
never before have humans consciously
changed the genetic code of a
free-living organism on this scale once
we do it there is no going back so it
has to be done right because there could
be unwanted consequences if we set out
to edit nature in the specific case of
malaria though the risk might be
acceptable since the genetic
modification doesn't make a big change
in the overall genome it only changes a
very specific part the worst-case
scenario here is probably that it might
not work or that the parasite adapts in
a negative way there is still much
debate
technology as powerful as Jeanne drive
needs to be handled with a lot of care
but at some point we have to ask
ourselves is it unethical to not use
this technology when every day 1000
children died humanity has to decide how
to act on this in the next few years the
public discussion is way behind the
technology in this case what do you
think this video was made possible in
part by viewer donations on patreon if
you want to help us make more videos
like this and get nice rewards in return
you can do so here we really appreciate
it
if you want to learn more about the
topic of genetic engineering we have
another video about CRISPR and GMOs and
in case that's too much biology for you
here's a space playlist
[Music]